Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
女嘉宾:这个背景真的很劣宗
Female Guest: This background is really tacky.
女嘉宾:不觉得吗哈哈
Female Guest: Don't you think so? Haha.
Alice: 好甜
Alice: So sweet.
Alice:开嗑
Alice: Let's crack it open.
女嘉宾:这个背景特别劣宗
Female Guest: This background is especially tacky.
女嘉宾:你要是单独一个人坐在那就是后彩
Female Guest: If you sit there alone, it's just colorful.
女嘉宾:直接问你有哪位心动女嘉宾
Female Guest: I'll directly ask if there's any female guest you like.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
女嘉宾:然后什么给谁发了短信
Female Guest: And then who did you send a message to?
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: Alright.
Jake: 是是是
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
女嘉宾:然后说你的
Female Guest: And then talk about your...
Jack: 怎么玩
Jack: How to play?
女嘉宾:x没有选择你
Female Guest: X didn't choose you.
Jack: 可以啊可以啊
Jack: Alright, alright.
Jake: 上墙了对
Jake: It's posted on the wall, right?
Jake: 太专业了
Jake: So professional.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
Jack: 来来来想想拍氛围感的
Jack: Come on, let's think about creating an atmosphere.
Alice: 我没说话
Alice: I didn't say anything.
刘婷:我跟你说
Liu Ting: Let me tell you.
刘婷:你看看你
Liu Ting: Look at you.
Jack: 想想拍氛围感的可以可以那个
Jack: Think about creating an atmosphere, we can do that.
刘婷:口不择言
Liu Ting: Speaking without thinking.
刘婷:童颜无忌 童言无忌
Liu Ting: Innocent words, innocent face.
Alice:童言无忌
Alice: Innocent words.
Alice: 我比你大
Alice: I'm older than you.
Alice: 我是你姐
Alice: I'm your elder sister.
Alice: 我童言无忌
Alice: I speak innocently.
Alice: 没大没小
Alice: No respect for elders.
Alice: 倒返天罡
Alice: Going back and forth.
Alice: 快点我们俩能合照一张吗
Alice: Hurry, can we take a picture together?
Alice: 我我想跟她合照
Alice: I want to take a picture with her.
Alice: 有一张很有爱的
Alice: A really lovely one.
刘婷:什么叫很有
Liu Ting: What do you mean really lovely?
Alice: 表情给我管理好
Alice: Control your expression.
Alice:来
Alice: Come on.
刘婷:一定要带着眼镜吗
Liu Ting: Do I have to wear glasses?
女嘉宾:雌雄双煞一样
Female Guest: Like a double threat
女嘉宾:你们俩干什么呢
Female Guest: What are you two doing?
Jack: 黑白双煞 黑白双煞
Jack: Black and white duo, black and white duo
Alice: 快点
Alice: Hurry up
Alice: 这墙是
Alice: This wall is...
女嘉宾:哇
Female Guest: Wow
Alice: 能不能搂着我呀来
Alice: Can you hold me, come on
Jack: 那边叫神仙眷侣这边叫黑白双煞
Jack: Over there they call it a perfect match, here it's a black and white duo
Alice: 哈哈来吧
Alice: Haha, come on
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on
Alice: 好僵硬
Alice: So stiff
女嘉宾:是我的
Female Guest: It's mine
Jack: 对被迫营业啊
Jack: Yeah, it's forced business
女嘉宾:太难看了
Female Guest: So ugly
Jack: 这个这个这个这个这叫被迫营业啊
Jack: This, this, this, this, this is called forced business
Jack: 这个叫被迫营业啊
Jack: This is called forced business
Alice:一看就不是真情侣知道吗
Alice: You can tell they're not a real couple, you know
Jack: 这个这个叫黑白双煞
Jack: This, this is called a black and white duo
刘婷:什么 这个真情侣不完蛋了吗
Liu Ting: What, if they're a real couple, they're done for
Alice:我真笑死
Alice: I'm dying of laughter
Jack: 上面在写个匾
Jack: Write a plaque above
女嘉宾:ok
Female Guest: Okay
Jack: 被迫营业啊黑白双煞
Jack: Forced business, black and white duo
Jack: 然后
Jack: And then
Jack: 哎  哎
Jack: Hey, hey
Jack: 画风突变
Jack: Sudden change of style
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Alice:这才真情侣
Alice: Now that's a real couple
刘婷:男士没了
Liu Ting: The man is gone
Alice:跟你就拍不出这种感觉
Alice: You can't get this feeling with you
刘婷:因为我们本来就是就是
Liu Ting: Because we are, we are...
Alice:低智哈哈哈
Alice: Low IQ, hahaha
刘婷:契约
Liu Ting: A contract
Alice: 哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha
刘婷:就是行婚你知道吗
Liu Ting: It's a sham marriage, you know
Alice:我靠 谁跟你行婚
Alice: Damn, who has a sham marriage with you
Alice:我行婚都不想跟你行婚你去死吧你啊
Alice: I wouldn't even want a sham marriage with you, go to hell
Alice:来低智
Alice: Come on, low IQ
Alice:我现在就来驯服我的手脚
Alice: Now I'll tame my hands and feet
Alice:没耳机啊
Alice: No headphones?
刘婷:这个动作会
Liu Ting: This move will...
Jake:倔强 倔强青铜
Jake: Stubborn, stubborn bronze.
Alice:低智
Alice: Low intelligence.
女嘉宾:我也是四肢不齐
Female Guest: My limbs are also uneven.
Alice:给我备注全名
Alice: Save my full name for me.
刘婷:哎这个如何
Liu Ting: Hey, how about this?
Alice: 给我 我靠 太难了
Alice: Give it to me. Oh my god, it's so hard.
女嘉宾:好弱智的小视频
Female Guest: Such a dumb little video.
Alice:他天天给我发这个
Alice: He sends me this every day.
刘婷:挺好玩的这个
Liu Ting: This is pretty fun.
刘婷:这是
Liu Ting: This is...
Alice:我不要跟你跳这个
Alice: I don't want to dance this with you.
Alice:我这机器掉了我给你说啊你今天你就走不了了
Alice: If this machine falls, I'm telling you, you're not leaving today.
刘婷:你还挑 ok ok
Liu Ting: You're still picky. Ok, ok.
刘婷:这个
Liu Ting: This...
Alice:我要这个
Alice: I want this one.
Alice:学不会啊
Alice: I can't learn it.
刘婷:左人 右 左右各一个人
Liu Ting: Left person, right, one on each side.
Shure: 后期这边全打码
Shure: We'll blur everything in post-production.
Alice:你能教我吗
Alice: Can you teach me?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  啊没事没事
Shure: Oh, it's fine, it's fine.
Jake:那带什么眼镜
Jake: Then what glasses should we wear?
Shure的女友:我也想问啊
Shure's GF: I also want to ask.
Shure:  没事那你给贡献一下也是可以的
Shure: It's okay, you can contribute too if you want.
Shure的女友:不可以
Shure's GF: No, I can't.
Shure的女友:我不可以
Shure's GF: I can't.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright.
Jake:好给您处理好吗
Jake: Okay, we'll handle it for you, alright?
Shure: 给你眼睛打个码
Shure: We'll blur your eyes.
Lucia:啊 找我吗
Lucia: Huh, are you looking for me?
Alice:你想参加我们的低智小视频吗
Alice: Do you want to join our low intelligence video?
Lucia:什么低智小视频
Lucia: What low intelligence video?
Alice:来来来 你让她看
Alice: Come on, show her.
女嘉宾:等一下我把这个连上
Female Guest: Wait, let me connect this.
Alice: 声音放大
Alice: Turn up the volume.
Jake: 这样你们这段声音可以闭掉是吧
Jake: So you can mute this part, right?
女嘉宾:最后最后
Female Guest: At the end, at the end.
Shure的女友:不 图像也不可以
Shure's GF: No, the image can't be used either.
Jake: 图像也不可以
Jake: The image can't be used.
Shure: 图像可以可以
Shure: The image can be used, it can.
Jake: 为啥
Jake: Why?
Shure的女友:不可以
Shure's GF: It can't be used.
Jake: 行了全打码吧
Jake: Fine, let's blur it all.
Shure的女友:声音其实没问题但是图像不可以
Shure's GF: The audio is actually okay, but the image can't be used.
Jake:好好那也可以
Jake: Okay, that's fine.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
男嘉宾:咱俩聊聊
Male Guest: Let's chat.
Jake:这是市场需要的
Jake: This is what the market needs.
男嘉宾:第一视角第二视角
Male Guest: First-person view, second-person view.
Jake: 对 那确实
Jake: Yes, that's true.
男嘉宾:太有必要了
Male Guest: It's really necessary.
Lucia:可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
刘婷:快 你学好吗
Liu Ting: Quick, did you learn it?
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What?
我们那天跳舞应该找他们的哦
We should have invited them to dance that day.
Alice: 怎么记住啊
Alice: How do you remember it?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:不是我们 是他这种低智视频
Alice: Not us, it's his kind of low-IQ videos.
女嘉宾:别别不要给我乱戴帽子
Female Guest: No, no, don't label me like that.
Alice: 祖奶
Alice: Grandma.
Jake: 来来来我要看我要看
Jake: Come on, I want to see it.
Jake: 导演把导演版拿出来
Jake: Director, show the director's cut.
刘婷:拍低智 过来 行
Liu Ting: Shoot the low-IQ one, come on, okay.
Alice:让他拍哈哈哈哈
Alice: Let him shoot, hahaha.
刘婷:然后
Liu Ting: And then...
Alice:这样啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Like this, hahaha.
刘婷:后退 等一下
Liu Ting: Step back, wait a second.
刘婷:ok
Liu Ting: Okay.
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this.
刘婷:这样 然后你直到啊一声
Liu Ting: Like this, then you shout "ah".
刘婷:开始
Liu Ting: Start.
女嘉宾:起事
Female Guest: Begin.
Lucia:起
Lucia: Start.
Lucia:这是咱今天晚上保留节目吗
Lucia: Is this our reserved program for tonight?
刘婷:对 然后你
Liu Ting: Yes, then you...
刘婷:呃
Liu Ting: Uh...
Alice:不是
Alice: No.
刘婷:这是我们的
Liu Ting: This is ours.
Jack: 可以是可以是
Jack: Sure, sure.
Lucia:可以是可以是
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Jake: 挺好挺好的
Jake: It's pretty good.
Lucia:来我帮你拍
Lucia: Here, let me take a picture for you.
刘婷:AI识别不出来了怎么办
Liu Ting: What do we do if the AI can't recognize it?
Jake: 最好让它识别出来对
Jake: It's best to make it recognize it, yes.
刘婷:ok 你就就就是最后面那个人
Liu Ting: Okay, you are the one at the very back.
Lucia:现在就是开了
Lucia: Now it's on.
Lucia:你要不要先调一下这些各种 参数之类的这些
Lucia: Do you want to adjust all these parameters first?
刘婷:然后我们前面有两个人
Liu Ting: And we have two people in front.
Jack: 我看看没什么需要调的
Jack: Let me see, there's nothing that needs adjusting.
刘婷:然后这个之后我们就 双臂展开
Liu Ting: After this, we spread our arms.
Jack: 然后你就看你喜欢的背景就可以了
Jack: Then just choose the background you like.
刘婷:抓紧 你知道吧
Liu Ting: Hurry up, you know?
刘婷:展开展开我忘  我忘  我也忘了 应该是
Liu Ting: Spread out, spread out, I forgot, I forgot, I think.
Lucia:你来选择
Lucia: You choose.
Katrina: 就没找过我了
Katrina: They haven't asked me yet.
Lucia:或者你刚刚就是帮大家拍的时候
Lucia: Or when you were helping everyone take pictures just now.
Lucia:你觉得哪里好看你就站哪里就行
Lucia: Just stand wherever you think looks good.
Shure的女友:已经很片面地了解了我的性取向
刘婷:然后 右 左
Liu Ting: Then right, left.
Katrina:  还没怎么去了解呢
Katrina: Haven't really understood it yet.
刘婷:右左
Liu Ting: Right, left.
Katrina:  我应该是做容器那一块
Katrina: I should be in the container section.
刘婷:然后
Liu Ting: Then...
Jake: 好大劲啊
Jake: So strong.
Alice: 不是 这什么时候出 什么时候收啊
Alice: No, when does it come out? When do we collect?
Lucia:你是换了个镜头吗
Lucia: Did you switch lenses?
Jack: 没有啊如果你
Jack: No, if you...
Lucia:是调焦啊ok 了
Lucia: Adjust the focus, okay.
刘婷:协调一点嘛
Liu Ting: Coordinate a bit.
Lucia: OK OK来试试吧
Lucia: OK, OK, let's try it.
Jake: 我就不试
Jake: I'm not trying it.
Lucia: 不是他咋又黑了
Lucia: Why is it dark again?
Lucia: OK OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK, OK.
刘婷:起 右 左
Liu Ting: Up, right, left.
Katrina:  嗯嗯 可以去游戏公司 但是
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, I can go to a gaming company, but...
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 哎呀懂了
Alice: Ah, got it.
Shure的女友:OK啊我回家
Shure: OK, I'm heading home.
Shure的女友:我带个小朋友回家
Shure's GF: I'm taking a kid home.
刘婷:左右踏步
Liu Ting: Step to the left and right.
Alice: 这不是踏步
Alice: That's not stepping.
Alice: 这不是扭腿吗
Alice: Isn't that twisting your leg?
Shure: 吓死我以为你说小朋友是是我
Shure: You scared me, I thought you were saying the kid was me.
Lucia:为啥是连拍
Lucia: Why is it a continuous shot?
Alice: 啊我觉得太抽象了
Alice: Ah, I think it's too abstract.
Lucia: 拍了好多张
Lucia: Took so many shots.
刘婷:那就是
Liu Ting: So that's it.
Alice: 不行不行还是要这个
Alice: No, no, we still need this one.
Alice:在哪
Alice: Where is it?
Lucia:这个光感好像不太用
Lucia: This lighting doesn't seem right.
Alice:啊 不是这个
Alice: Ah, not this one.
刘婷:拍之前那个嫌难度高
Liu Ting: The one before was too difficult.
刘婷:拍这哎
Liu Ting: Shoot this one, hey.
Alice: 哎呀 不难 我学
Alice: Oh, it's not hard, I'll learn.
Jake: 哎你干嘛呢自闭啦
Jake: Hey, what are you doing? Are you closing yourself off?
Jake: 你在干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake: 打游戏hello
Jake: Playing games, hello?
男嘉宾:打游戏
Male Guest: Playing games.
Jake: 睡觉啊
Jake: Sleeping?
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:学不
Alice: Learning?
Jake: 那我们下去玩吧
Jake: Then let's go downstairs and play.
Jake: 哈哈哈 不知道
Jake: Hahaha, I don't know.
Jake: 不知道带着眼镜下去采一点
Jake: I don't know, maybe wearing glasses will help.
Jake: 或者你要休息啊
Jake: Or do you want to rest?
Jake: 发烧了 好 是
Jake: Fever, okay, yes.
Jake:好 是 发烧了 唉  好
Jake: Okay, yes, fever, sigh, okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈打游戏
Jake: Hahaha, playing games.
Jake: 下去打去哈哈哈
Jake: Go downstairs to play, haha.
Jake:都在玩呢有啥差别
Jake: Everyone's playing, what's the difference?
Alice: 我又不用分散
Alice: I don't need to distract.
Lucia:跑了相机不好相相机没拍出你的这个
Lucia: The camera didn't capture your heroic posture.
Lucia:这个这个英姿飒爽是吧
Lucia: This, this heroic posture, right?
Jake:在这里在这里
Jake: Here, here.
刘婷:这不关你的事
Liu Ting: It's none of your business.
Alice: 啊这个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ah, this, hahaha.
刘婷:你 你不是这个苗子我天呢
Liu Ting: You, you're not the right fit, oh my god.
刘婷:如何
Liu Ting: How is it?
Lucia:特别好
Lucia: Really good.
Alice:好像学会了又好像没学会
Alice: Feels like I learned it, but also not really.
Alice: 你你要不要参与我们
Alice: Do you want to join us?
Jake:早来一点 我靠
Jake: Come a bit earlier, damn.
Alice:脸 哈哈哈Lucia你来嘛
Alice: Face it, hahaha, Lucia come on.
Alice: 我是摸屁股这个
Alice: I’m the one touching the butt.
Alice: 哈哈哈不是哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha, no, hahaha.
Lucia:不行
Lucia: No way.
Alice:你是哈哈那个
Alice: You’re the laughing one.
刘婷:这是不是太近了
Liu Ting: Isn’t this too close?
Lucia:如何一句话劝退别人是吗
Lucia: How to discourage someone with one sentence, right?
Jake: 让我整这个
Jake: Let me handle this.
Nicous: 我怕把你吓着了
Nicous: I’m afraid I’ll scare you.
Shure的女友:你别扇别扇别扇别扇别扇
Shure's GF: Don’t slap, don’t slap, don’t slap.
刘婷:就是可能会伤害他的眼睛
Liu Ting: It might hurt his eyes.
Jake:见证一下
Jake: Witness this.
Nicous: 关健是他本忘了他叫什么
Nicous: The key is he forgot his name.
Alice: 这别我腰上的
Alice: Don’t touch my waist.
Nicous: 找到修硕都没听清
Nicous: Even Shure didn’t hear it clearly.
Shure的女友:你没有存我备注吗那时候
Shure: L O R
Shure的女友: L O R C H I D
Shure's GF: L O R C H I D
Shure的女友:哦
Shure's GF: Oh.
Shure的女友:不是
Shure's GF: No.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
Nicous: 你加我嘛
Nicous: You added me, right?
Jake:开机啦
Jake: It's on!
Lucia:迅速进入角色
Lucia: Quickly get into character.
刘婷:你看你看
Liu Ting: Look, look.
刘婷:无所谓拍的好不好无所谓
Liu Ting: Doesn't matter if it's good or not, it doesn't matter.
刘婷:重在参与好不好 重在参与
Liu Ting: Participation is what counts, right? Participation.
刘婷:有信心吗
Liu Ting: Are you confident?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
刘婷:没有我不
Liu Ting: No, I...
刘婷:你要有
Liu Ting: You have to be.
Jake: 你怎样
Jake: How are you?
Lucia:响亮的答案没有
Lucia: Loud and clear, no.
Shure: 哈哈哈没有没有
Shure: Hahaha, no, no.
刘婷:要有要有要有
Liu Ting: We need it, we need it, we need it.
刘婷:OK我们看一下我们看一下
Liu Ting: OK, let's take a look, let's take a look.
Lucia:我们没有
Lucia: We don't have it.
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: It's possible.
Jake: 你要变身
Jake: You need to transform.
Shure:  怎么有人驾着的开始
Shure: Why is someone driving to start?
刘婷:你看一下位置
Liu Ting: Check the position.
Katrina:  靖康导师导师我可以拿这个拍张照吗
Katrina: Coach Jingkang, can I take a photo with this?
刘婷:这这这那
Liu Ting: This, this, and that.
Jake:啊 没问题你自己改 你随便改
Jake: Ah, no problem, you can change it however you like.
Jake:你随便改一下都可以
Jake: You can change it however you want.
Katrina: 哈哈哈看哪光好
Katrina: Hahaha, let's see where the light is good.
Jack: 这这黄哪光都那样
Jack: The light is the same everywhere.
Jake: 可以打光要不要搬出来
Jake: We can use lighting, do you want to move it out?
Jake:那我搬出来
Jake: Then I'll move it out.
Jack: 那可以
Jack: That's fine.
刘婷:哎呦 不对哦
Liu Ting: Oh no, that's not right.
Jake:那我搬出来
Jake: Then I'll move it out.
Alice: 那这边不就没地了
Alice: Then there will be no space here.
Jake: 姐 帮帮忙呗
Jake: Sis, help me out.
Tasha:说
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 那个一会
Jake: Later,
Jake: 叫我们一起
Jake: call us together.
Jake: 把充电宝给 不是 插电板给弄下来
Jake: to take down the power strip.
Tasha:好呀
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Jake:我去
Jake: I'll go.
Jake: 就这样录一下你们祥是哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just record it like this, you guys are hilarious, hahaha.
Lucia:然后下一个是我是吧
Lucia: Then I'm next, right?
Lucia:啊这样子
Lucia: Ah, like this.
Lucia:然后还是接着动啊哈哈
Lucia: And keep moving, haha.
Alice: 玩不了一点哈哈哈
Alice: Can't play at all, hahaha.
Jack: 你们这个
Jack: You guys are...
刘婷:存个草稿
Liu Ting: Save a draft.
Shure的女友:然后随便是在我那个
Shure: Then just randomly in my...
Jake: 呃我拉插线板会长一点
Jake: Uh, I'll pull the power strip to make it longer.
Alice:看看
Alice: Let's see.
Jack: 他色温可以调吗
Jack: Can you adjust the color temperature?
Jake:我不会了
Jake: I can't do it anymore.
Jake: 他很便宜啊
Jake: It's really cheap.
Jack: 那就这样了
Jack: So that's it then.
Jake: 好嘞 能强点是吧
Jake: Alright, can we make it stronger?
Jack: 不是 色温可以重新
Jack: No, we can redo the color temperature.
刘婷:存草稿吧存草稿
Unknown: Save it as a draft, save it as a draft.
Shure的女友:我那还有
Shure: I still have it.
Alice:哎呦 我笑死了
Alice: Oh my, I'm dying of laughter.
女嘉宾:再来一遍
Female Guest: Let's do it again.
刘婷:有信心吗
Unknown: Do you have confidence?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 看补光灯有效果没
Katrina: Check if the fill light is effective.
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia:响亮的答复 没有
Lucia: Loud and clear, no.
Alice:没有我们先休息一会
Alice: No, let's take a break first.
Alice: 不急于一时
Alice: No rush.
刘婷:行 没事
Unknown: Okay, no problem.
Alice: 反正有个草稿了
Alice: Anyway, we have a draft.
刘婷:我们
Unknown: We...
刘婷:我们有这一个版其实已经很不错了
Unknown: We already have a version, which is quite good.
Tasha: 哎他 不是
Tasha: Hey, he... no.
Jake:你说
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Jake:什么什么东西
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha:啊 没有人吧 我就是好奇一下
Tasha: Ah, nobody, I'm just curious.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:没有关系
Tasha: It doesn't matter.
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:我不知道 我真不知道
Jake: I don't know, I really don't know.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 我们工作上
Jake: We at work...
Jake: 哈哈哈保持工作上的联系
Jake: Haha, we maintain work contact.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha:只 只 只
Tasha: Just, just, just...
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Okay
Jake: 也不是 我没问过我也没太懂
Jake: Not really, I never asked, so I don't really understand.
Tasha:要干嘛呀
Tasha: What are we doing?
Jake:呃 拔掉
Jake: Uh, unplug it.
Jake: 我去拔我去拔
Jake: I'll unplug it, I'll unplug it.
Tasha:这个嘛
Tasha: This one?
Tasha:这个吗
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:the
Tasha: The...
Jake:the
Jake: The...
Tasha:the
Tasha: The...
Jake:the
Jake: The...
Tasha:this
Tasha: This...
Tasha:and the
Tasha: And the...
Tasha:我靠你就不能买个长的吗
Tasha: Oh my god, couldn't you just buy a longer one?
Tasha:你买俩小短的
Tasha: You bought two short ones.
Jake: 嘿嘿
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:经费有限
Jake: Budget is limited.
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK.
Jake:经费有限
Jake: Budget is limited.
女嘉宾:一会伸手不见五指
Female Guest: Soon you won't be able to see your hand in front of your face.
Lucia:不是不是修硕要
Lucia: No, no, it's Shure who...
Katrina: 唱歌
Katrina: Sing.
Katrina:  啊修硕 唱歌
Katrina: Ah, Shure, sing.
Lucia:不是修硕要跳舞来着的吗
Lucia: Wasn't Shure going to dance?
Jake: 对啊修硕跳舞唱歌
Jake: Yes, Shure dances and sings.
Katrina:  修硕跳舞
Katrina: Shure dances.
Lucia:不是修硕要干好多事来着吗
Lucia: Didn't Shure have a lot of things to do?
Katrina:  哈哈哈核心主力吗
Katrina: Haha, the main force, right?
Shure:  我怕回去他不认我了
Shure: I'm afraid he won't recognize me when I go back.
Katrina: 哈哈你跳个舞她也跟你和好了
Katrina: Haha, if you dance, she'll get back with you.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Alright.
Shure: 他分在哪跳啊
Shure: Where is he going to dance?
Katrina:  他学什么舞种
Katrina: What kind of dance is he learning?
Shure的女友:你问他咯
Shure's GF: Ask him.
Katrina:  不会学拉丁吧
Katrina: Not Latin dance, right?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Alice:我去送他一下
Alice: I'll walk him out.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye bye
Jake:没开过
Jake: Never done it before
Jake:头回开
Jake: First time
Alice:开过 但忘了
Alice: Done it before, but forgot
刘婷:哦哟 慢点慢点
Liu Ting: Oh, slow down, slow down
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Alice:那我就录着这个走啦
Alice: Alright, I'll record this while we go
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay okay okay
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye bye
Jake: 对 两个gester送走
Jake: Yeah, sent off two guests
Jake: 送走两位gester
Jake: Sent off the two guests
Katrina: 我们预计八点结束还没有唱一首歌
Katrina: We planned to end at eight but haven't sung a song yet
Katrina: 你还没表演你的才艺呢
Katrina: You haven't performed your talent yet
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yeah
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay
Lucia:相信您的技术
Lucia: Trust your skills
Jake:哎我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Lucia:哎我觉得这张很好对对对
Lucia: Oh, I think this one's really good, yeah yeah yeah
男嘉宾:你拍我脸干嘛呀
Male Guest: Why are you taking a picture of my face?
女嘉宾:这打光自拍
Female Guest: It's for a well-lit selfie
Lucia:最后最后那张就是我
Lucia: The last one, the last one is me
Lucia:就是那个角度的话
Lucia: From that angle
Lucia:我的脸型会有点有点胖
Lucia: My face looks a bit chubby
Lucia:但是前面几张都很好
Lucia: But the earlier ones are all good
Jake: 还没开始呢就让我清场
Jake: Haven't even started and I'm asked to clear the field
Jake: 别忘了那三首歌啊 我靠 哈哈哈
Jake: Don't forget those three songs, oh my gosh hahaha
Lucia:没事没事可以了
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, it's fine
Katrina:  修硕
Katrina: Shure
Jake: 修硕你选的三首歌了
Jake: Shure, your three songs
Lucia:只有偶偶然有发挥失误的时候也很正常是吧
Lucia: It's only natural to have occasional performance mistakes, right?
Jake: 修硕你选的三首歌呢
Jake: Shure, your three songs?
Shure: 我选的三首歌
Shure: The three songs I picked
Katrina: 一起唱呗
Katrina: Let's sing together
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Katrina: new boy这首
Katrina: The song "New Boy"
Shure的女友:拍你们不行吗
Shure's GF: Can't I take a picture of you guys?
Jack: 你俩是唯一正经的情侣
Jack: You two are the only serious couple
Shure: 什么叫正经
Shure: What do you mean by serious?
Shure: 你们这些回去都不能说是吧
Shure: You guys can't talk about this when you go back, right?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure的女友:我们这都不是CP
Shure's GF: We're not even a couple.
Shure: 哦好好好
Shure: Oh, okay, okay.
男嘉宾:我们我们这个
Male Guest: We, we...
Katrina: 我看用手机拍
Katrina: I think I can take a photo with my phone.
Shure的女友:咦不要
Shure's GF: Eww, no.
Katrina:  我试试给你们拍一组壁纸出来
Katrina: I'll try to take some wallpaper shots for you guys.
Jake:两个ego币
Jake: Two ego coins.
Jake:现在也挺好的是不是
Jake: It's pretty good now, right?
Jake:蹲下去了这个就不行了
Jake: If you squat, it won't work.
女嘉宾:哈你
Female Guest: Ha, you...
男嘉宾:没有入镜
Male Guest: Not in the frame.
Tasha:你就差一点
Tasha: You were so close.
女嘉宾:可以
Female Guest: Okay.
Shure的女友:就是我们俩这个情况比较复杂
Shure's GF: Our situation is pretty complicated.
Shure的女友:你知道吗
Shure's GF: You know?
Jake:啊
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jack: 什么情况比较复杂
Jack: What's so complicated?
Jake:啊什么叫复杂什么叫复杂
Jake: What do you mean by complicated? What do you mean?
Jack: 什么叫复杂
Jack: What's complicated?
Katrina: 拍 拍 拍到非公开群里
Katrina: Take, take, post in the private group.
男嘉宾:哪里复杂
Male Guest: What's complicated?
Katrina: 这是
Katrina: This is...
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Shure: 没有没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no, no.
Jake: 你要给我们送一集多少信息
Jake: How much information are you going to give us in one episode?
Jack: 怎么复杂
Jack: How is it complicated?
Jake:咱能飙一下午咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep going all afternoon?
Jake:咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep going?
Jack: 到时候到时候这涉及到一个问题
Jack: There's an issue with that.
Jack: 为什么复杂然后发给修硕他
Jack: Why is it complicated? Send it to Shure.
Jack: 发给修硕填填填答案呢
Jack: Send it to Shure to fill in the answers.
Jake:好嘞 行 等着嘞
Jake: Alright, got it, waiting.
Jack: 那个灰鸟灰得什么情况笑场
Jack: What is that grey bird doing? Laughing?
男嘉宾:你俩能互相看一下吗
Male Guest: Can you two look at each other?
Lucia:这样看好像有点暗
Lucia: It looks a bit dark like this.
男嘉宾:快快快
Male Guest: Quick, quick, quick.
Jake:哎呀妈
Jake: Oh my god.
Jack: 这这个看法不太不太正常
Jack: This opinion is kind of unusual.
Katrina: 你俩别整的像暧昧气一样行吗
Katrina: Can you two stop acting all flirty?
Jack: 你们俩搞得像你们俩
Jack: You two are acting like...
Jack: 现在还在害羞非常暧昧
Jack: You're still shy and very flirty.
Shure:  没有
Shure: No.
Jack: 所以是暧昧期吗
Jack: So, is this the flirting phase?
Katrina: 还老夫老妻了暧昧去
Katrina: More like an old married couple.
Lucia:我自拍的时候其实不知道应该看哪
Lucia: When I take selfies, I never know where to look.
Jack: 看着也不像啊
Jack: Doesn't look like it.
Jake:多久了 我也不懂我也不懂
Jake: How long has it been? I don’t get it, I don’t get it.
男嘉宾:我也不懂我也很好奇
Male Guest: I don’t get it either, I’m curious.
Jake:回去你自己飙啊
Jake: Go home and figure it out yourself.
男嘉宾:最后两张
Male Guest: Last two pictures.
Jake: 哈哈哈 我是飙不了的
Jake: Haha, I can’t figure it out.
Shure: 来来来必须给
Shure: Come on, gotta give it a try.
Jake:我是飙不了
Jack: 到正到时问起就哎放
Jack: When it’s time to ask, just ask.
Jake:这玩意飙不了啦
Nicous: 这是要打自己一巴掌
Nicous: This is like slapping yourself.
Katrina: 理解不了
Katrina: I can’t understand.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:我们俩总有一个人模糊拍
Lucia: One of us always ends up blurry in the photo.
Jake:拍破防了 我草
Jake: Broke my defenses, damn.
Lucia:对这张还行
Lucia: Yeah, this one’s alright.
Jake:拍到了吧是吧
Jake: Got it, right?
Jake:反正我们是都录了
Jake: Anyway, we recorded it all.
男嘉宾:没电了
Male Guest: Battery's dead.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
男嘉宾:看不见
Male Guest: Can’t see.
Jack: 没事还有电
Jack: No worries, there’s still battery.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Good.
Lucia:对这张好像反光弱一些
Lucia: Yeah, this one’s got less glare.
Shure: 是的都是我们配的一环
Shure: Yep, it’s all part of our setup.
Jake:我觉得是第一个学习机里有接吻片的
Jake: I think it’s the first learning device with kissing scenes.
Jake: 第一视角接吻照片
Jake: First-person view of kissing photos.
Shure: 怎么以后以后以后
Shure: How about in the future, in the future...
Jack: 我刚我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I just miss?
Jake:马上给他们看一眼
Jake: I'll show them in a bit.
Shure:  所有那个学生会议都要邀请我俩去亲一下是吧
Shure: Every student meeting should invite us to kiss, right?
Jack: 我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I just miss?
Tasha: 这里面有 上一张
Tasha: There’s more, the previous one.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:我们第一张图片配合第一张图片就是这个哇
Jake: Our first picture matches with the first picture, it's this one.
Jack: 让我看看 来来来先先
Jack: Let me see. Come on, come on, first.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Katrina: 看看看
Katrina: Look, look, look.
Katrina:  拍到了吗看看
Katrina: Did you take it? Look.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Jake:啊好妙啊
Jake: Ah, it's so wonderful.
Jack: 看了一下正点啊
Jack: Checked it, it's on point.
Shure的女友:分手了只要钱到位也没关系
Shure's GF: Breaking up is fine as long as the money is right.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 哇 来给我拍一张
Katrina: Wow, come take a picture of me.
Lucia:对 我觉得这边这个好一点
Lucia: Yeah, I think this one over here is better.
Shure: 可以可以过去在亲的这是没有问题
Shure: Sure, sure, go ahead, there's no problem with that.
Jack: 分手钱给到位也没问题
Nicous: 分手了也没有关系吗
Nicous: Breaking up is no problem?
Shure: 又不是没分过
Shure: It's not like it hasn't happened before.
Katrina:  是发群里吧
Katrina: Post it in the group, right?
Katrina:  发群里公开
Katrina: Post it in the group, make it public.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
女嘉宾:全部都交给露亚了啊
Female Guest: Leave everything to Lucia.
Shure的女友:要不然怎么会说情况很复杂呢
Shure's GF: Otherwise, why would they say the situation is complicated?
Jake:还有四张图
Jake: There are four more pictures.
Jake:哦哦差了四张图是吧
Jake: Oh, oh, we're missing four pictures, right?
男嘉宾:拍四张类型的拼过去
Male Guest: Take four types and stitch them together.
Lucia:然后我直接转发到群里
Lucia: Then I'll forward it directly to the group.
Jake:OK  OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake: 妙
Jake: Wonderful.
Nicous: 有点郁闷睡觉了
Nicous: Feeling a bit depressed, going to sleep.
Jack: 这关系真的是很复杂
Jack: This relationship is really complicated.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 哎呀
Jake: Oh man.
Shure: 先放着吧
Shure: Just leave it for now.
Jake:抽两根要
Jake: Need to smoke two.
Jack: 这Paty活动适合拍照
Jack: This party is perfect for taking pictures.
Jake: 该唱歌的人在那呢
Jake: The one who should be singing is over there.
男嘉宾:唱歌唱歌
Male Guest: Sing, sing.
Jake:该唱歌的人在这整活了
Jake: The one who should be singing is doing something else here.
Jack: 唱啊开唱唱唱唱唱
Jack: Sing, come on, start singing, sing, sing, sing, sing!
Shure: 啊唱唱唱唱唱唱唱什么
Shure: Ah, sing, sing, sing, sing what?
Jake:整活了太忙了
Jake: Too busy with all the activities.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 我们要唱什么来着
Shure: What are we supposed to sing?
Shure: 是不是说说说给大家
Shure: Shouldn't we tell everyone?
Shure: 我的我的我的teammates
Shure: My, my, my teammates.
Shure:  我的我的roommates呢
Shure: Where are my roommates?
Shure:  roommates上里面调小药水去了
Shure: Roommates are mixing potions inside.
Jake: 这这你调酒去了
Jake: Mixing drinks over there?
Jake: 你又唱
Jake: You sing again.
Lucia:你有teammates你不是说好了我自己solo吗
Lucia: You have teammates? Didn't we agree I would solo?
女嘉宾:不是说好了我自己solo吗
Female Guest: Didn't we agree I would solo?
Jake:solo 对呀
Jake: Solo, right.
Shure: 什么solo不是
Shure: What solo? No.
Jake:solo dancer
Jake: Solo dancer.
Alice:真没走过路姐们
Alice: Seriously, never walked this path before.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 没关系你想要哪张就哪张
Tasha: It's alright, you can pick whichever one you want.
女嘉宾:给个这个吧
Female Guest: Give me this one.
Shure: 不不上去还是在下边上去是吗
Shure: Should I go up or stay down here?
Jake: 哎都行听你的
Jake: Hey, whatever you want.
Jack: 就在下边吧
Jack: Just stay down here.
Jake: 行在下面呆着吧
Jake: Okay, just stay here.
Lucia:现在是
Lucia: Now it's...
Alice:温度还好啊
Alice: The temperature is alright.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:已经都7:40了快
Lucia: It's almost 7:40.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes.
女嘉宾:那两个guest已经走了
Female Guest: Those two guests already left.
女嘉宾:guest
Female Guest: Guest.
Lucia:这个柯欣的guest
Lucia: This is Kexin's guest.
Shure:  谁记得我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Who remembers where I put my iPad?
Shure:  我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Where did I put my iPad?
Jake:会有这种数据我靠
Jake: There would be such data? Damn.
Shure:  你有印象吗
Shure: Do you have any idea?
Lucia:你试试那个寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: Try using the Find My iPhone feature.
Jake: 哦你在找吗
Jake: Oh, are you looking for it?
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Shure: 没有我的iPad
Shure: I can't find my iPad.
Lucia:修硕不是找不到
Lucia: Shure didn't lose it.
Shure:  忘记了放哪了
Shure: I just forgot where I put it.
Lucia:我说可以试试寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: I said you could try the "Find My iPhone" feature.
Jake: 咋的呀
Jake: What's up?
Jake: 不是这个不是这个薇薇的
Jake: No, this isn't it. This belongs to Tasha.
Lucia:这个应该是薇薇的吧
Lucia: This should be Tasha's, right?
Jake: 二楼没有吗
Jake: Not on the second floor?
Shure:  你有看到我的iPad吗
Shure: Have you seen my iPad?
Shure的女友:在楼上
Shure's GF: It's upstairs.
Shure的女友:就在那个水池旁边
Shure's GF: Right next to the sink.
Lucia:这两天这个网怎么老是这么差
Lucia: Why has the internet been so bad these past two days?
Jake:是我也发现了
Jake: Yeah, I've noticed that too.
Katrina: 去二楼活动还是去哪活动啊
Katrina: Are we going to the second floor to hang out or somewhere else?
Jake:二楼活动
Jake: Second floor.
Jake:或者外面都行
Jake: Or outside, either works.
Jake:看设备在哪
Jake: Depends on where the equipment is.
Katrina: 准备
Katrina: Alright.
Katrina: 上才艺
Katrina: Time to perform.
Katrina: 撤退
Katrina: Retreat.
Katrina: 什么撤退了
Katrina: What do you mean retreat?
Lucia:哎你今天回学校吗
Lucia: Hey, are you going back to school today?
Katrina: 哦快8点了
Katrina: Oh, it's almost 8 o'clock.
Katrina: 因为我们整体活动往后延了一个小时
Katrina: Because our whole schedule got delayed by an hour.
Jake:我们不是6:40准时
Jake: Weren't we supposed to start at 6:40 sharp?
Jake:4.07准时开始是吗
Jake: Or was it 4:07 sharp?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia:为什么大家都站着我坐着
Lucia: Why is everyone standing while I'm sitting?
Katrina: 上二楼坐
Katrina: Sit on the second floor.
Jake:嗯没事没事
Jake: Yeah, it's fine, no worries.
Lucia:起立
Lucia: Stand up.
Katrina: 上二楼坐一会你在走
Katrina: Sit on the second floor for a while, then you can go.
Katrina: 那你那你明天还来吗你们
Katrina: Are you coming again tomorrow?
Jake:哎呀要上去了
Jake: Oh, we're heading up.
Tasha:怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Tasha:我上来他们下来我也来他们上来
Tasha: I come up, they go down, I come down, they go up.
Jake:没逗你
Jake: Not joking with you.
Jake:可没逗您
Jake: Seriously, not joking.
Jake:放下
Jake: Put it down.
Jake:唉放这里
Jake: Yeah, put it here.
Jake:还得往里走一点
Jake: Move it a bit further inside.
Jake:要插电板吗
Jake: Do you need a power strip?
Shure: 不用了
Shure: No, it's okay.
Jake:不用了 好嘞
Jake: No? Alright then.
Nicous: 你音箱接上了没
Nicous: Did you connect the speakers?
Shure: 音箱他们都接一起了我记得
Shure: Yeah, I think they connected all the speakers together.
Shure: 对插这个
Shure: Yeah, plug this in.
Jack: 这这个是个啥呀
Jack: What is this thing?
Shure: 这就是个声卡
Shure: This is just a sound card.
Shure: 哎这要插线板
Shure: Hey, we need a power strip.
Shure: 谁把这个插线板拔下去了
Shure: Who unplugged the power strip?
Shure: 我打算就回去上两天班看看心情
Shure: I was planning to go back to work for a couple of days, see how I feel.
Jake:我啊 拔下去的呀
Jake: I did, I unplugged it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:修 要琴吗
Unknown: Shure, do you need the piano?
Shure: 哎要琴
Shure: Yeah, we need the piano.
Shure: 你先
Shure: You first.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Jack: 来我给你主持一波
Jack: Let me host this for you.
Nicous: 听说你今晚不走了走了
Nicous: I heard you're not leaving tonight.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Jake:啊你还要走啊
Jake: Oh, you're leaving?
Jake:你不能走啊
Jake: You can't leave.
Shure: 我不能走么
Shure: I can't leave?
Jake:你你也能走
Jake: You can leave too.
Shure: 我我主要
Shure: I mainly...
Shure: 我主要想
Shure: I mainly want...
Shure: 明
Shure: Tomorrow...
Jake:想干嘛想想毕业
Jake: What do you want to do? Thinking about graduation?
Shure: 明天上班主要是
Shure: Mainly to work tomorrow.
Nicous: 明天上班
Nicous: Work tomorrow.
Shure: 明天
Shure: Tomorrow.
Jake:来插线板
Jake: Come on, power strip.
Shure: 因为
Shure: Because...
Shure: 其实再再呆一天
Shure: Actually, if I stay another day...
Shure: 我翘了一周班
Shure: I've skipped work for a week.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jack: 哦血亏2100 至少2100
Jack: Oh, lost at least 2100.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:带薪翘班还是啥
Jake: Was it paid leave or what?
Jack: 你给他300一天网易少给他300一天
Jack: You give him 300 a day, but NetEase gives him 300 less.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, is that how it is?
Shure: 网易就150
Shure: NetEase only gives 150.
Shure: 我一天
Shure: For a day.
Jake:那你一直在我身上 对啊
Jake: So you've always been with me. Right?
Lucia:哦 其实赚了
Lucia: Oh, actually, you earned more.
Shure: 而而且
Shure: And, and...
Jake:对啊 那你回去干嘛
Jake: Yeah, so why go back?
Jake:那你回去干嘛
Jake: So why go back?
Katrina: 明天待一天还有300呢
Katrina: Stay another day, you get another 300.
Shure: 也也也也有道理
Shure: That, that makes sense.
Jack: 对啊那那那
Jack: Yeah, so...
Shure: 待一天吧待一天吧
Shure: Stay one more day, stay one more day.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:谁呀我啊
Sue: Who, me?
Jack: 既然都不能转正摸就摸吧
Jack: Since we can't make it permanent, just go with the flow.
Jake:确实 就是雇大家来摸鱼啦
Jake:你们带着眼镜就行
Jake: Just wear glasses.
Shure: 来 我来我来
Shure: Here, let me do it, let me do it.
Jake:干啥都行
Jake: Whatever you do is fine.
Katrina: 哈哈哈拍一下我们提倡摸鱼的老板
Katrina: Hahaha, let's take a picture of our boss who encourages slacking off.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真好人
Katrina: Hahaha, what a good person.
Katrina: 睡到11点不带叫你醒的
Katrina: Sleep until 11, no one will wake you.
Jack: 是吗
Jack: Really?
Jack: 喂喂
Jack: Hello, hello.
Jake:咦 少个人少人是吧
Jake: Hey, someone is missing, right?
Katrina: 少谁啊
Katrina: Who's missing?
Jake:坐地上可以
Katrina: 薇薇啊
Katrina: Tasha.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Katrina: 哦还有那个
Katrina: Oh, and...
Katrina: 柯欣是吗
Katrina: Kexin, right?
Jake:柯欣
Jake: Kexin.
Jake:坐地上
Jake: Sit on the floor.
Shure: 来吧我在703
Shure: Come on, I'm in 703.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我们没有排过任何一遍
Katrina: Hahaha, we've never rehearsed even once.
Katrina: 真的的可以吗
Katrina: Really, is that okay?
Shure: 可以
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:这是默契
Jake: This is synergy.
Jake:已经毕业了
Jake: Already graduated.
Shure: 对就是默契
Shure: Yeah, it's all about the chemistry.
Jake:对这是提前培养的默契
Jake: Yeah, this chemistry was developed early on.
Katrina: 等等等薇薇他们回来要不要一起
Katrina: Wait, wait, should we wait for Tasha and them to come back?
男嘉宾:不如在这个时候
Male Guest: How about we do it now?
Jake:薇薇走了
Jake: Tasha left.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Jake:姐
Jake: Sis.
Jake:薇薇
Jake: Tasha.
Tasha:不要感我姐
Tasha: Don't call me sis.
Jake:那喊你什么呀
Jake: Then what should I call you?
Jake:怎么不戴眼镜
Jake: Why aren't you wearing glasses?
Tasha:因为在做
Tasha: Because I'm doing...
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:因为在做什么
Jake: Because you're doing what?
Tasha:不要喊我姐我比你小吧
Tasha: Don't call me sis, I'm younger than you, right?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:好 征求你说
Jake: Okay, I'll listen to you.
Tasha:你几几年的
Tasha: What year are you born in?
Jake:我95年的
Jake: I was born in '95.
Tasha:好 哥
Tasha: Okay, bro.
Jake:好  走
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Jake:请
Jake: After you.
Tasha:去楼上干啥
Tasha: What are we doing upstairs?
Jake:我
Jake: I...
Tasha:我不会唱歌
Tasha: I can't sing.
Jake:没关系我也不会
Jake: It's okay, I can't either.
Tasha:那你去干啥
Tasha: Then what are we going to do?
Jake:去看着 就是活动嘛 走一遍流程
Jake: Just watching, it's an event, going through the motions.
Tasha:好吧 石头剪刀布
Tasha: Alright, rock-paper-scissors.
Jake:对 走
Jake: Yeah, let's go.
Jake:然后呢
Jake: And then?
Tasha:我赢了的话
Tasha: If I win...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah?
Tasha:你就扶我下来
Tasha: You have to help me down.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:我输了的话
Tasha: If I lose...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah?
Tasha:你就扶着凳子
Tasha: You have to hold the stool.
Jake:噢 好行 来
Jake: Oh, alright. Come on.
Tasha:不行
Tasha: No way.
Tasha:三局两胜 哈哈哈
Tasha: Best of three. Hahaha.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好 扶你下来
Jake: Alright, let me help you down.
Katrina: 好一起唱呗
Katrina: Okay, let's sing together.
Jake:怎么扶
Jake: How should I help?
Shure: 来吧大家会的就一起唱
Shure: Come on, everyone who knows the song, sing along.
Tasha:不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Katrina: 给你拍个绝美
Katrina: I'll take a stunning photo of you.
Lucia:你要擦那个相机吗还是
Lucia: Do you want to clean the camera or...
Jake:那请您 请您
Jake: Please, go ahead.
Jake:怎么怎么清
Jake: How do I clean it?
Tasha:不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:那有点难喂
Jake: That's a bit difficult.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey.
Jake:哈哈哈我去
Jake: Hahaha, I'm going.
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done.
Katrina: 好 好听
Katrina: Okay, sounds good.
Tasha:我赢了
Tasha: I won.
Jake:怎么怎么清下来着
Jake: How do I clean it again?
Tasha:不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:好难啊
Jake: It's really hard.
Jake:请您下来
Jake: Please, step down.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Tasha:行行行
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Tasha:我害怕
Tasha: I'm scared.
Jake:唉 我去 还是还是这么下来了
Jake: Sigh, here we go, still coming down like this.
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:好
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:请
Tasha:嗯  好
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Shure: 对着点我嘴
Shure: Aim it at my mouth.
Shure: 话筒一点升收不进去
Shure: The mic needs to be a bit higher, it's not picking up.
Jack: ok ok说声对不起
Jack: OK, OK, say sorry.
Shure: 哈哈哈喂喂哎
Shure: Hahaha, hey hey.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: Laughing to death.
Jake:哦忘词是吧
Jake: Oh, forgot the lyrics, huh?
Jake:放词行吗
Jake: Can we put the lyrics on?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:在大屏幕上放词
Jake: Put the lyrics on the big screen.
Katrina: 这是这是
Katrina: This is, this is...
Katrina: 这是彩排啊
Katrina: This is just a rehearsal.
Shure: 哈哈哈刚才是试音好吧
Shure: Hahaha, we were just testing the sound.
男嘉宾:主要是试音
Male Guest: Mainly testing the sound.
Shure: 好吧也也能看到
Shure: Okay, but you can also see it.
Katrina: 试音
Katrina: Sound test.
男嘉宾:他这个看不到词
Male Guest: He can't see the lyrics.
男嘉宾:对对对
Male Guest: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 也也能看到
Shure: But you can see it.
Nicous: 这词有点小
Nicous: The lyrics are a bit small.
男嘉宾:大
Male Guest: Big.
男嘉宾:可以可以
Male Guest: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 可以看到可以看到啊
Shure: You can see it, you can see it.
男嘉宾:可以看到可以看到
Male Guest: You can see it, you can see it.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 那你要面对这边面吗
Katrina: Do you want to face this way?
男嘉宾:那你可以重来还是接着来
Male Guest: Do you want to start over or continue?
Shure: 从头来
Shure: Start from the beginning.
男嘉宾:从头来从头来
Male Guest: Start from the beginning, start from the beginning.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 保证
Shure: Promise.
Katrina: 有勇气
Katrina: Courage.
Lucia:没事没事这个不是玻璃
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, this isn't glass.
Shure: 啥玩意碎了
Shure: What broke?
Lucia:这是个啥呀
Lucia: What is this?
女嘉宾:杨老板杨老板
Female Guest: Jake, Jake!
Jake:呃给我给我就好了
Jake: Uh, give it to me, give it to me.
Lucia:ok ok
Lucia: OK, OK.
Jake:对对
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 下一首还有还有下一首
Shure: Next song, there's another song.
Nicous: 加个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano.
男嘉宾:还有下一首
Male Guest: Another song.
Katrina: 你想弹什么你弹
Katrina: Play whatever you want.
Nicous: 前面加一个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano at the beginning.
Katrina: 来啊
Katrina: Go ahead.
Jack: 可以
Jack: Sure.
Jack: 流沙
Jack: Quicksand.
Shure: 我们是不是还说要唱new boy来着啊
Shure: Didn't we say we were going to sing "New Boy"?
Katrina: 都行都行
Katrina: Anything's fine, anything's fine.
Katrina: 反正发现就还是咱几个人
Katrina: Anyway, it’s still just us.
男嘉宾:唱什么
Male Guest: What should we sing?
Katrina: 那随便唱
Katrina: Just sing whatever.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let’s go.
Jake:对都在掌握中
Jake: Yeah, it's all under control.
Jake:你随便唱
Jake: Just sing whatever.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything’s under control.
Shure: 那个XBZ你
Shure: Hey, Nicous, you...
Nicous: 你把麦关了
Nicous: Turn off the mic.
Shure: 你 你弹一个D调的卡农的和弦会吗
Shure: Can you play a D chord for Canon?
Nicous: 可以
Nicous: Sure.
Shure: 不不 你就弹D调卡农和弦就行
Shure: No, no, just play the D chord for Canon.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything’s under control.
Nicous: 很高级
Nicous: Very advanced.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 就是
Shure: That’s it.
Katrina: 就么看我房间还是很好看的哈哈
Katrina: Look, my room is still very nice, haha.
Shure: 找一下吧
Shure: Let’s find it.
Shure: 哎呀歌词就行
Shure: Oh, just the lyrics.
Shure: 这个
Shure: Here.
Shure: 让大家
Shure: Let everyone...
Jake:对是其他挺费劲的
Jake: Yeah, it's quite tricky otherwise.
Shure: 能能能找明白不
Shure: Can you figure it out?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Nicous: 是这个吗
Nicous: Is it this one?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Close enough.
Shure: 相信你
Shure: I trust you.
刘婷:怎么顶格了
Liu Ting: Why is it aligned?
Shure: 第一个是这个
Shure: The first one is this.
Shure: 拍什么曲子
Shure: What song to shoot?
Shure: new boy
Shure: New Boy.
Jake:哎薇薇呢
Jake:又翘班了
Jake: Skipping work again?
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Jake:不行不行
Jake: Not okay, not okay.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not okay.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let’s go.
Jake:得上来摸鱼
Jake: Gotta come and slack off.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not allowed.
Shure: one
Shure: two
Shure: one two three
Jake:打电话了 好嘞
Jake: Making a call now. Alright.
Tasha:对对
Tasha: Yes, yes.
Tasha:我妈妈
Tasha: My mom.
Jake:好啊
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你好你好
Jake: Hello, hello.
Jake:好你你忙你忙
Jake: Alright, you go ahead.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:没有我叫你上去
Jake: No, I asked you to go up.
Tasha:叫我上去干嘛
Tasha: Why did you ask me to go up?
Jake:上去参加活动
Jake: To join the event.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:眼镜呢
Tasha:挂电话了 刚才打电话我放我就放在
Tasha: Hung up the call. I just placed it...
Jake:啊行行行 好
Jake: Ah, okay, okay. Fine.
Jake:下去接妈妈的电话去
Jake: Go down and answer your mom's call.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Jake:哈哈哈沙雕
Jake: Hahaha, silly.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Shure: 行了行了行了可以了可以了
Shure: Alright, alright, alright, that's enough, that's enough.
Katrina: 哈哈哈谱还没对象
Katrina: Hahaha, still no partner.
Katrina: 结束了
Katrina: It's over.
Shure: 来吧你你的难忘今宵了吧该
Shure: Come on, it's your turn to sing "Unforgettable Tonight."
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jack: 啊 谁难忘今宵了
Jack: Ah, who's singing "Unforgettable Tonight"?
Nicous: 那你调下声
Nicous: Then adjust the voice.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 人呢还有一个
Shure: Where's the other person?
Shure: 还有一个XBZ同学要为大家带来的一首歌曲
Shure: There's another student, XBZ, who's going to sing a song for everyone.
Shure: 叫
Shure: Called...
Nicous: 谢彬竹和修硕的
Nicous: Xie Binzhu and Shure's...
Shure: 没有我没有我
Shure: No, not me, not me.
Nicous: 你这比我重要了
Nicous: You're more important than me.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This...
Shure: 我比你重要什么
Shure: How am I more important than you?
Shure: 我给你选一个好听的音色就好了
Shure: I'll just choose a nice tone for you.
Nicous: 给我切换一下
Nicous: Switch it for me.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Nicous: 用手指切换
Nicous: Use your fingers to switch
Shure: 来吧XBZ同学
Shure: Come on, XBZ
Shure: 没有他
Shure: He's not here
Katrina: 呵呵 这弹出来
Katrina: Haha, it popped out
男嘉宾:有点想哭了 音乐出来就想哭
Male Guest: I feel like crying, the music makes me want to cry
Katrina: 这是背景音吧
Katrina: Is this the background music?
男嘉宾:这加了特效音乐
Male Guest: They added some special effect music
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh
Katrina: 天呐 如听仙月耳在鸣哈哈
Katrina: Oh my, like hearing celestial music, haha
Jack: 准备 准准备开哭
Jack: Get ready, prepare to cry
Katrina: 这什么歌
Katrina: What song is this?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable Tonight
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Shure: 今夜我们在此欢聚
Shure: Tonight we gather here
Alice:我靠
Alice: Oh my god
男嘉宾:哎哟喂
Male Guest: Oh my
Katrina: 说不清
Katrina: Can't explain it
Shure: 今夜我们在此快乐
Shure: Tonight we are happy here
Nicous: 再再来一点
Nicous: A bit more
男嘉宾:已经开饮一天了
Male Guest: Been drinking all day
Alice:这什么环节啊
Alice: What segment is this?
Katrina: 忘记今宵
Katrina: Forget Tonight
Shure的女友:难忘今宵
Shure's GF: Unforgettable Tonight
Jake:赶上clothing了
Jake: Just in time for clothing
Shure: 我们相聚一堂
Shure: We gather together
Shure: 在这ego house
Shure: Here in this ego house
Jack: 什么呀
Jack: What is this?
Alice:有点抽象
Alice: It's a bit abstract
Jake:我跟你哈哈哈哈
Jake: I'll laugh with you, hahaha
刘婷:ego house
Liu Ting: Ego house
Jack: 顺间就服气了
Jack: Suddenly I'm impressed
女嘉宾:你们坐吧
Female Guest: You guys sit down
Shure: 我们难忘今宵
Shure: We will never forget tonight
Shure: 我们难忘未来
Shure: We will never forget the future
Jack: 难忘未来什么
Jack: Never forget the future, what?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈你忘什么东西
Jake: Hahahaha, what are you forgetting?
男嘉宾:我笑死了
Male Guest: I'm dying of laughter
Katrina: 还没过呢就难忘
Katrina: It's not even over yet and it's unforgettable
Alice:难忘未来可还行
Alice: Unforgettable future, really?
Shure: 我们难忘过去
Shure: We can't forget the past.
Shure: 来吧 朋友
Shure: Come on, friend.
Jake:快进门
Jake: Hurry, come in.
Shure: 牵着你的手
Shure: Holding your hand.
女嘉宾:要退票了
Female Guest: I need to cancel the ticket.
Shure: 就让
Shure: Just let...
Shure: 昨天的烦恼都忘掉
Shure: Forget all the worries from yesterday.
Jake:傻瓜
Jake: Fool.
Shure: 去迎接明天的快乐吧
Shure: Let's embrace the happiness of tomorrow.
Katrina: 在做心灵SPA啊
Katrina: Doing a spiritual spa, huh?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jack: 还啊的一声
Jack: Still saying "ah"?
Alice:我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Shure: 多好啊
Shure: How great is this.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Nicous: 我有点感觉这个谱子不太对啊
Nicous: I feel like this tune isn't quite right.
Shure: 挺好的
Shure: It's fine.
男嘉宾:没有
Male Guest: No.
Jake:这叫离谱你懂吗
Jake: This is what we call outrageous, you know?
Shure: 这个我们就叫做离谱对吧
Shure: We just call this outrageous, right?
Jack: 没有
Jack: No.
Jack: 滚你这看起来就不算有谱不能叫离谱
Jack: Get out of here, this doesn't even count as having a tune, it can't be called outrageous.
Nicous: 他没有背歌词
Nicous: He didn't memorize the lyrics.
Nicous: 他在玩茶流鸡我草
Nicous: He's messing around, damn.
Jack: 让我猜他己经醉了
Jack: Let me guess, he's already drunk.
Jake:哈哈已经唱完了
Jake: Haha, it's already over.
Shure: 没有没有我们这就是诗朗诵环节
Shure: No, no, this is our poetry recitation segment.
Jake:哎好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure: 难忘今宵表演者
Shure: Unforgettable Tonight performers.
Shure: Ego life全体成员
Shure: Ego Life team members.
Jake:啥 哈哈
Jake: What? Haha.
Katrina: 立的都爬了
Katrina: They're all up now.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
男嘉宾:所以所以你们这一个礼拜
Male Guest: So, so you guys have been this crazy all week?
女嘉宾:退票
Female Guest: Cancel the ticket.
男嘉宾:都是天天这么精神病吗
Male Guest: Are you guys always this crazy every day?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 新来的朋友啊
Shure: New friends, huh?
Shure: 我们每天都很快乐
Shure: We're happy every day.
Shure: 来吧快来到美好的ego life吧
Shure: Come on, come quickly to the wonderful Ego Life.
Jack: 美好啊是没有好那个好吧
Jack: Beautiful? No, it's not good, right?
Shure: ego life是一个
Shure: Ego life is a
Shure: 快乐的大家庭
Shure: Happy big family
Shure: 是一个没有纷争的大家庭
Shure: It's a big family without disputes
Shure: 是一个完蛋
Shure: It's a total mess
Shure: 我被美女包围了的大家庭
Shure: A big family where I'm surrounded by beautiful women
Shure: Ego life
Jack: 就这句话比较现实
Jack: This statement is more realistic
Shure: 带给了我快乐
Shure: It brings me joy
Katrina: 这是诗歌朗诵
Katrina: This is poetry recitation
Shure: 带给了我金币
Shure: It brings me gold coins
Jake:Ego Coin
Jake: Ego Coin